PROFESSOR: So let's
look at two examples
of using the
well-ordering principle.
One of them is pretty
obvious, and the other one
is not hard but a little
bit more interesting.
So what we're going to prove
is that every integer greater
than one is a product of primes.
So remember a prime is
an integer greater than 1
that is only divisible by
itself and the number 1.
It can't be expressed as
the product of other numbers
greater than 1.
So the way we're going to
prove this is by contradiction,
and we're going to
begin by assuming
suppose that there
were some numbers that
were non-products of primes.
OK.
That is to say, the set of
non-products is non-empty.
So applying the least--
the well-ordering principle
to this non-empty
set of non-products,
there's got to be a least one,
so m is a number greater than 1
that is not a product of primes.
Now, by convention, if
m itself was a prime,
it's considered to be
a product of one prime,
so we know that
m is not a prime.
Now look.
M is not a prime, or
if it was a prime,
it would be a product
of just itself,
so that means that it must
be a product of two numbers,
call them j and k, where
j and k are greater than 1
and less than m.
That's what it means to
be a non-prime-- it's
a product of j and k.
Well, j and k are
less than m, so that
means that they must be prime
products, because they're
less than m and
greater than 1, and m
is the smallest such number
that's not a product of primes.
So we can assume that j is equal
to some product of prime say,
p1 through p94, and k is
some other product of primes,
q1 through q13, so you can
see where this is going.
Now what we have is
that m, which is jk,
is simply the
product of those p's
followed by the product
of those q's and is,
in fact, a prime product
which is a contradiction.
So what did we assume that
led to the contradiction?
We assumed that there were
some counter-examples,
and there must not be any,
and no counter-examples
means that, in fact, every
single integer greater than 1
is indeed a product of
primes as [AUDIO OUT].
Let's start looking at a
slightly more interesting
example using the
well-ordered principle
to reasoning about postage.
So suppose that we
have a bunch of $0.05
stamps and $0.03
stamps, and what
I want to analyze is
what amounts of postage
can you make out of $0.05
stamps and $0.03 stamps?
So I'm going to introduce
a technical definition
for convenience.
Let's say that a
number n is postal.
If I can make n plus
$0.08 postage from $0.03
and $0.05 stamps.
So this is what
I'm going to prove.
I claim that every
number is postal.
In other words, I can make
every amount of postage
from $0.08 up.
I'm going to prove
this by applying
the well-ordering
principle, and as
usual with
well-ordering principles
we'll begin by
supposing that there was
a number that wasn't postal.
That would be a
counter-example, so if there's
any number that's not
postal, then there's
at least one m by the
well-ordering principal,
because the set of
counter-examples
is non-empty if some
number is not postal,
so there's at least one.
So what we know,
in other words, is
that this least m that's
not postal has the property.
It's not postal, and any
number less than it is postal.
See what we can
figure out about m.
First of all, m is not 0-- 0
is postal, because 0 plus $0.08
can be made with a $0.03
stamp and a $0.05 stamp.
M is not 0, because m is
supposed to be not postal.
As a matter of fact,
by the same reasoning,
m is not 1 because you can make
1 plus $0.08 with three $0.03,
and m is not 2, because you
can make 2 plus $0.08-- $0.10--
using two $0.05.
So we've just figured out that
this least counter-example has
to be greater than
or equal to 3,
because 0, 1, and 2 are
not counter-examples.
So we've got that
m is greater than
or equal to 3, the
least non-postal number,
so if I look at m
minus 3, that means
it's a number that's
greater than or equal to 0,
and it's less than
m, so it's postal,
because m is the
least non-postal one.
So, in other words, I can make--
out of $0.03 and $0.05 stamps,
I can make m minus 3
plus $0.08 but, look,
if I can make m
minus 3 plus $0.08,
then obviously m is postal
also, because I just
add $0.03 to that
and minus 3 number,
and I wind up with
m plus $0.08, which
says that m is postal
and is a contradiction.
So assuming that there was
a least non-postal number,
I reach a contradiction
and therefore there
is no non-postal number.
Every number is postal--
0 plus 8 is postal,
1 plus 8 is postal,
2 plus 8 is postal.
Every number greater
than or equal to $0.08
can be made out of
$0.03 and $0.05 stamps.